oh
[Music]
because trump is
[Music]
[Music]
no this is happening
this is happening no it's already
happening i don't want to trade the
station i don't want to do this left the
station
[Music]
sorry
should have knocked
should have knocked didn't knock
ah
talk to some of the parents who are
concerned exposing children to kind of
sexualized content we're introducing
otherness so they can um be loving
accepting people i'll be happy sexual
happening in here this is not about
children this is not about opening their
eyes to this and making them see this
this is a pg performance like it's for
it's family friendly completely pg
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sorry about that dave i regrew my
mustache and she knocked it off i know
i know
is that oh is that what do you have on
there did you you guys don't give him
the rib eye no okay
all right well i guess i'll do it now i
rarely do any commercials on the outside
of the show but uh can i have it uh yeah
you can yes you please do keep it don't
put it back in the
office freezer go to goodranchers.com
crowder
and uh you can use a code crowder at
checkout you get 30 off right now for uh
because we're talking about labor day
yeah coming up soon are you guys going
to be cooking you get 30 off
your uh first order free shipping on any
box and you get it for life
we did this last thursday right we did
this last thursday and then the show got
completely corrupted yes and didn't work
because you heard like every other word
like when you're trying to get off a
phone call right going seltzer was
eating through the wire he was eating
through the wires yeah established that
all right glad to be with you uh we have
a lot to get to today i don't know if
you know this but science now and
actual guidelines for academic research
journals
no longer can be scientific they have to
be considerate and if science could be
seen as discriminatory
sexually racially
based on gender i guess that doesn't
apply us actually at this point
scientists are being advised to change
it we'll get into that also new
guidelines for kovid what we can say and
what we cannot say on youtube did you
know that yeah we can say more yeah so
we can show the aaron rodgers interview
oh well that's that was on with rogan
yeah we're allowed to do that now we're
not not not in the past so uh we'll be
talking what else are we talking about
today let me check here we have uh
we have all kinds of fun oh that's right
canada lgbtq i don't know if you saw
this there's a hundred million dollars
in canada now going to fund the lgbtq
they can't even get the acronym right
i'm going to read you from read to you
from a government-funded news entity in
canada cbc and five times in one article
they get the acronym wrong which is a
problem when you understand that jordan
peterson came to power came to success
came to the the public eye because he
refused to comply
with language that they don't even
follow themselves so you comply or you
can be fined or you can be put in jail
we actually have the language police in
quebec by the way that's an act that was
an actual thing when i grew up but they
can't even get it straight themselves so
uh a lot to get to uh gerald a how are
you sir i'm doing well how are you i'm
fine yeah a little little uh
discombobulated today we had a lot a lot
of stuff that we had to fix here do you
like my shirt by the way what's your
shirt say it's my mortgage identifies as
a student loan oh that's cute i think i
like it and agree with it yeah i do
should right now yeah i mean like you're
giving away money yeah i mean if you
give it for forgive rent but you don't
forgive mortgages yeah how does that
make sense just do the whole thing oh we
want an entire permanent class of
renters yeah and uh by the way uh i love
him you love him fastest man on his feet
he's going to be with me both of us the
two of us who's splitting the time in
houston on september 17th at the uh
smart financial center in sugarland you
can go to lightercutter.com tour dave
landa how are you sir ahoy good how
about you i'm doing is you're wow you're
i healed quickly i know it's crazy
well it's the good ranchers that's right
nothing will fix a good eye well that
i'm sure that's not the slogan they want
that and the fact that he was part of
weapon dave x program the adamantium
helps true
can you pull that promo back up for
houston nothing nothing like playing
into the stereotype that technically
means nothing but farmland yeah i don't
know it's more like indiana eight
million people yeah
i definitely look like somebody who
would hit a gal in that photo yes you do
like come on you would windmill yeah
it's just like in the past yeah very
good
horses to the theater and to be clear uh
the head count is four million but uh
many of them houston count is two so
wait that's that's true
it's not eight i know uh so we do okay
we have this right now so before we get
to anything else uh
we can talk about how uh you know trans
women fail to look uh like real women
all the time but here's the thing now
you've heard the term barely passables
trans men trying their best to to pass
two
[Music]
more
you know
if that person
it would be tough to tell that person
apart from sophia loren it would
it's also her body was so
feminine yes
we have the thing coming up on thursday
the drag queen story hour deal uh it was
actually a distillery which i'm
surprised that kids were allowed it was
stripping for children that'll be out
thursday there are actually some
there's some more hidden camera footage
that hasn't made it to the public eye
yet but i
i wanted to just uh at first we said
let's take uh let's let's do a public uh
just stripping of straight people an
outdoor strip club with kids and of
course that would not be allowed you
can't go against decency laws ah but i
thought what we can do is at least just
have beautiful women and you know old
strapping lads and just uh have kids
like hey isn't that a pretty woman
hey hey ladies isn't that guy look like
prince charming and no no i'm not
talking about scantily clad and just
watch people lose their minds now it's a
problem just to recognize that isn't it
weird that christians that christian
conservatives who didn't want the
objectification of of of women right so
this was a whole thing when you look
back in the day they were saying oh you
know what rap videos probably shouldn't
be for kids at this point now we're
saying oh hold on a second we probably
need to show some more tna of actual
women
well that would at least balance this
kid yes it would balance it out yes well
yeah well you mean real ones yeah what
did i just watch
what did i just watch it wrong what just
happened well first of all why does she
get to have that body if you want to be
a man you need to look like girl
yeah exactly yeah you don't just get to
be perfect that has to be an upgrade
that's earned you would think so where's
your beer belly get some hairs that are
in gross awful places yeah have some
moments smell bad yes smell awful yeah
pepper some ingrown hairs in there you
probably will after walking around
wearing rubber all day right but hey
go for a jog just ask michael keaton
by the way it's a live show monday
through thursday 10am eastern is the
best way to tune in i don't know if
notifications are working if you guys
could comment below if you're on youtube
let me know if notifications are working
a lot of you are saying that they have
not so you can watch us on rumble or of
course on mug club you can download the
podcast just don't rely on notifications
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
that's the best way to tune in all right
i'm gonna move right on to uh aaron
rodgers here oh
this wonderful quarterback yes now
here's the thing i don't know aaron
rodgers very much you don't i don't know
anything about sports he makes a
quarterback yeah
okay
he's good for real yes he's because he
looks like cm punk pre-tattooed he's
very good he's one of the best
okay no i've heard he's very good but he
got a lot of flack obviously because it
was unvaccinated a while ago and at one
one point in time we wouldn't have been
able to really discuss this remember
when we first covered the story we had
to be careful as to what we could say on
youtube what we couldn't because we
could be we were banned we were
suspended for discussing yeah you you
the coveted vaccines and the cdc numbers
shouldn't have done the good thing is
the rules have changed now oh good so we
can show this to you uh this weekend on
rogan which you've seen already but i
want to then refresh your memory on the
controversy that uh that surrounded
aaron rodgers for a long time
uh he had some pretty interesting takes
on what's happened with the nfl's
absolutely insane covet virtue signaling
they didn't give a [ __ ]
you want to play football take this
[ __ ] thing and i want you to do it
publicly so that i can get more money
out of those other people that are
thinking about it and they're on the
fence
yeah and then we're going to virtue
signal to say look how righteous our
league is we have 95 compliance yes with
the vaccine compliance and if you don't
we're going to send a su it's like tree
bleacher snyder to show you graphs this
looks like a bit of a douche there
you're vaccinating
persistence
compared to the rest of the leak now
which actually happened really yeah what
was the stooge like
oh i mopped the floor with them did you
yeah see again that's why people like no
one knew your vaccination status you
lied to your teammates no no day three
of training camp they sent the stooge in
and and he showed these slides about
what your vaccination percentage was in
your team where you compare the rest of
the
league
and i started asking them questions
about
liability
well i'm not a lawyer okay
i'm the legal community will be stunned
to find out you are not amongst them
yeah i think are they were they watching
tape on vaccination
all right team sit down it's john madden
doing his play live yeah look here
here's where he takes the he takes a jab
right there and he still gets covered
anyway fourth
booster wow
better center
for some reason his heart stopped i have
no idea
got kobe brain
[Laughter]
and uh and we're gonna get to then and
now but uh let me just give you again
just so you have the full context i
recommend that you go watch the full joe
rogan interview some really good stuff
has been happening on the show lately uh
he continued to explain how the
protocols in the nfl and and i will say
this rationalizing it in a way that you
wouldn't always expect from a
professional athlete so it's not because
he's famous i think he makes some good
points and he talks about specifically
the protocols in the nfl and and how
they make no sense poking holes in it
here
well it's not only going to affect your
uh day-to-day status on the team but
your ability to get a job the ability to
keep a job your ability to get a try out
if you get cut from this team
because you want to put a percentage
above 90 of your team where you guys can
have some sort of like special virtue
like look how amazing we are we're above
the 90 threshold here and then and then
they scared teams and said if you had an
outbreak
caused by a non-vaccinated player you
not only forfeit that game if you had
enough players out but you wouldn't get
paid for that week
and here i am showing up to training
camp joe the first day and we got five
people who work for the organization
out with covid all fully vexed
and i got covered from a
fully vaxxed individual who only got
vaxxed to keep his potential
of being a part of the nfl and this is
something that's important for everybody
to understand because i i've heard some
some liberal commentators discussing
saying oh comedians want to be able to
say whatever they want but they're a
very small percentage of the population
it doesn't affect you hold on a second
the ability to speak freely affects you
oh these star nfl athletes it doesn't
affect you so they can't go out and make
millions of dollars in the field hold on
a second it affects you in the same way
if your employer or if the government
decides to exert pressure on your
employer so that you now lose your job
prospects it affects losing your freedom
and by the way i don't mean
sort of uh in a nebulous way your very
fundamental freedoms bodily autonomy
right the right to privacy it of course
it affects all of you
this is one of those issues where it
does help for someone who has a high
profile has a platform to speak out
because it affects
for every aaron rodgers there there's
probably 10 million people who
experience the same thing in this
country only they're on the unemployment
line and they never get to tell their
story they never made the money that
aaron rodgers made right yeah my wife
was being faced with either get the
vaccine or you lose your job i remember
that and we'll talk about that in just a
minute how it affects pregnant women and
she was pregnant and nursing and i paid
you like crap but i know and i was like
we can't do that there's no way but look
it takes an aaron rodgers to do that in
the nfl if you're a third string
quarterback trying to make the team what
his point was third string quarterback
it doesn't matter why you're not getting
the vaccine you could have a health
condition you have some history with
vaccinations you could have some other
things that make it to where it's not a
safe thing for you to do
and there was no out just because the
nfl wanted to look good it took an aaron
rodgers who said i'm one of the best
quarterbacks in the league what are you
gonna do
right to stand up to the league and say
no i'm gonna start pushing back i'm
gonna start pushing back now what they
should have done
is walked out
they should have gotten together with
the players association and said
absolutely not and guess what today
they would have been vindicated
everybody would look back and go they're
right they should have done that but too
many people played ball because they
were worried about getting paid and
worried about being promoted and
sponsored did they play ball yes
those clever t-shirts yeah baby you have
a future in pinterest well meanwhile
with the
vaccination for cte in the nfl's like
i've never even heard of that that's a
concussion let's cover that up for 30
years you mean that crappy will smith
movie well they're trying to make up for
it dave leather helmets isn't it ironic
that will smith starred in the film
about uh cte and then gave it to chris
rock it's strange
i think he has it from scientology yes
how many times can you get electrocuted
your thetans aren't high enough one more
who knew you could get it from a woman's
glare yes
[Laughter]
no it's the it's the years of emotional
abuse
i think it's time america forgets
[Laughter]
not jada though no no no no if only for
her i'm on chris frock's side don't get
me wrong oh yeah yeah i mean come on
we all saw her the way she looks at him
yeah we did that you're saying you
wouldn't have gotten up inside i'm still
upset about her crappy accent in gotham
like what are you doing are you doing
you're doing an old south are you doing
an english accent well i don't know but
she has six inch fingernails
it works
do you ever see that she has it's like
the exaggerated acrylic like like she's
a velociraptor just please anyway the
point is she's unattractive both inside
and out regardless of her balding uh now
it's time to continue with aaron rodgers
this is important let's do it let's do a
then and now segment
[Music]
is that system of it down no i don't
think so this sounds like it could be
all right aaron's the one playing it
he's multi-talented i had no idea he was
armenian yeah
really
asking like what are we what are we what
are we gonna do we're gonna run the ball
down the fair
rover
just say hi
just say hurt
it's the same
i just hear it all as that he just looks
at the left guard doesn't like how he's
playing he's like wake up
all right
i'm ashamed of myself so let's go back
to then
because it's important to
don't expect better from this show today
remember everything went wrong when we
did stuff and we switched to rumble and
we have to switch things back to youtube
and so it's just it's just you know just
you i just youtube is the bane of my
existence but i get it it's like an
abuse it's like an abusive relationship
youtube is my jada
don't slap me shade a tube yes cheetah
pink it tube
[Music]
all right so they've changed their
policies now but for you to appreciate
it you need to understand what came
before you so let's go back to then
aaron rodgers of course he already hit
it that's okay cool man you know every
time i say then you notice this at a
softly because if i say the word then he
hits it like he doesn't do it no don't
don't when will then be now soon
aaron rodgers of course was ripped all
over the media for a stance on masks and
vaccines back in the day and by that i
mean like yesterday
here's my here's my issue with rogers
when he said the method by which he felt
he was immunized there is very there's
weak weak science and by weak science i
mean
peer reviewed double blinds what's the
sample size etc there's not strong
evidence scientifically for the vaccine
and what that tells me is this guys
it tells me that rogers by the way a lot
like kyrie irving to me they have
intellectual pride it's important to
them that you think that they're smart
right okay but aaron when you then get
into basically i guess good medicine you
don't want us to showing me that's right
is you really don't objection critical
thinking abilities to pick which and
choose which rules to follow
who is that guy
there's a big sports oh one of them
he's one of those guys he just has one
of those faces where involuntarily my
fist is like clinches yes no that's true
um so that was then now
and this is why we're allowed to talk
about this on youtube isn't it wonderful
the cdc's new covered recommendations
literally say unvaccinated people now
have the same guidance as vaccinated
people what youtube recently removed a
policy that stopped users from
questioning the effectiveness of masks
quietly
now let me just be clear about this the
reason they uh remove that is because
they don't work
it's freedom wait i love being able to
say it do you mean that for like
surgical procedures when put on with
gloves
i'm not exactly sure as to their
guidelines what i think they mean to say
is uh uh uh something along those lines
oh so they're not like for
chocolatey hands in a dirty airport
right
or wearing it for the 17th day in a row
yes it's stuffed in your glove box
chesterfields yes looks like a cheese
covered enchilada on your face keep in
mind we got in trouble early on on
youtube for saying that you actually can
build if you are sick yourself make your
own mask from a double
a a double weave or sorry double layered
antimicrobial pillow case and we said
it's not going to be a filter but it'll
help keep you from coughing droplets
onto other people sure when the cdc said
there was no effectiveness right and
that was because of the ppe shortage so
we forgive them for lying to the public
right yeah just magnify it right look at
every natural disaster film you can go
to dante's peak you could go to deep
impact you could go to any what happens
is the government lies because they
don't want to be embarrassed sure they
did it with masks and then they did it
again with masks
but it was just masks right well hold on
a second they want to tell you this was
the deadliest pandemic since i don't
know i guess the bird zika i don't know
zika to me from what i understand it's
like it didn't kill your kid gets born
with a weird shaped head yeah i'm sure
it killed some yeah no it's bad do what
i hear but my point is it doesn't affect
me so i don't care
so let's go back to
then
yeah
uh and this is something that i was
actually brought to my attention uh
yakuza and toolman were telling me about
this uh because i had forgotten i
remembered the initial outrage i
remember the initial opinion of this
news anchor or doctor i guess on cnn i
didn't know what had transpired entirely
so back then uh there was this covet
expert resident coveted expert on cnn dr
leanna wen um and she shamed the people
who didn't wear masks and called the
unvaccinated she actually called them
untrustworthy if that's not orwellian i
don't know what is but don't take my
word for it back in may when they lifted
the indoor mass requirement i thought
that the honor code was never going to
work that when vaccinated and
unvaccinated people are mixing unless
there is proof of vaccination everybody
should still be wearing masks and so i
actually support what the cdc is now
doing which is going back to this indoor
mask requirement because frankly we know
that we can't trust the unvaccinated
that they have been walking around
without masks and in fact that's what
led to the surge that we're seeing oh of
course it did we can't trust the
unvaccinated no now we would get in more
trouble on youtube if we quoted the cdc
and by the way all references we make
available lot of credit.com you have the
link in the description you can go to
the website we always do you may not
agree but we make all the references
publicly available she was saying don't
trust the unvaccinated yeah and then
claimed that the spike was because of
them without any evidence without
adjusting it you said that a deep rural
accent it would sound like it was out of
mississippi burning right yeah we don't
want to mix yeah we don't want to mix
them you won't come in when they're
mixed people my my daughter brings home
an own vaccinate it's gonna be real
problems i wanna look at my grandkids
and see my face yep this rap not some
mixed face no not some maskless mixed
face i don't want my kid mixing
dumbbroad now
this is where we are
dr wen has changed her stance completely
and she says that masks are a personal
choice her kids won't be wearing them
let me read the exact quote wait wait
wait
this is from the washington post dr
liana wynne unbelievable yeah masking
has harmed our son's language
development and limiting both kids
extracurriculars and social interactions
would negatively affect their childhood
and hinder my and my husband's ability
to work okay a couple of things here
and this is what the left is doing
because midterms are coming up i'm sorry
is that the same woman it's the same
woman
oh but the woman against mixing
heavens yes don't expect her at a our
local mixer that's odd anytime language
development not being able to look at
someone's mouth move yep yep she said
and because it affected her speech
issues with her son
um this is one of those issues where
because we're going into midterms
they're now saying well there might have
been some overreach but here's our
excuse we couldn't know yes you could
have
how because people like aaron rodgers
said there is science
that at the very least runs counter to
your signs if not refutes it we had it
on this show we had medical experts on
this show youtube facebook twitter
removed that content this idea that well
we couldn't have known that masks would
have negative effects
we cited the studies that showed you not
not only the kinds of negative social
effects that masks had but actual health
effects with children if they were
reusing masks because they were filthy
in the constant reinhalation right the
recycling of air where you're talking
about strep throat you're talking about
all these bacterial uh
possible infections we talked about this
a long time ago so for them to say well
hold on a second we did the best we
could with the science we had no no you
did the most effective lying you could
with the science you chose while
excluding everything else which you now
are accepting that's how you know it's
arbitrary yeah you panicked we had
science from over 100 years ago that
said lockdowns didn't work and then the
who actually said they didn't work
initially and then they changed their
stance on it and said yeah this is a
good policy for the world we knew it by
the way the the the video that we just
played of her was 15 months into the
pandemic yeah we knew by then at the
very least even if you want to okay fine
fine for the first 15 months you didn't
know that's not true but i'll give you
that
why did you make that comment in june of
2021 that you couldn't trust the
unvaccinated yeah but it was their fault
that we were having a spike none of that
was true
my giant leather bird mask filled with
potpourri worked just fine
i like the ones with holes in them
because you can breathe better yeah yeah
we're just fine better
she's she said not for her kids but
maybe for her i think she might might
suggest a ziploc baggie yes
you're not gonna catch anything a nice
wrap of saran you're not gonna get
nothing ain't gonna catch covert or your
breath nope yeah we'll be mixing we'll
be mixing won't be doing no mixing ain't
no vaccine i'm a doctor i'm not mixing
i want ovax babies pure blood
we're going to do a remake of look who's
coming to dinner so let me give you also
uh something
on vast person yes
and here's something else that's telling
is not only what they say but how they
choose to release the information right
in the dead of night we'll talk about on
mug club them firing that effort in the
heat of the night with a vex right yeah
they call me mistervax
so back then uh of course the american
cdc uh they said and we talked about
this on the show they said well
breastfeeding mothers uh may choose to
be vaccinated right i said well we don't
know and you and you and i taught you
your wife's a nurse the policy is if you
don't know for sure don't take it right
when you're pregnant that's always any
comment below any anyone out there who
has ever been pregnant
right or is pregnant right now what does
your doctor say if you say hey uh
there's now no long-term studies on this
should i should i take
what it a vitamin supplement should i
take whatever prescription it is vaccine
the policy is and it's a rule by the way
something about the hippocratic oath
first do no something something
something or other i forget the rest uh
don't do it unless we know for sure if
you're pregnant that's always been the
gold standard yeah but they said well we
don't know or in in absence of
information that it's 100 percent safe
right we've done every trial we know how
to do and all of the data comes back and
says no we haven't found a way yet for
it to hurt you right now they didn't
have any of that but now
okay the uk health department just
quietly again in night published that
the pfizer uh vaccine the biotech
whatever whichever one i can't remember
shouldn't be taken by breastfeeding
mothers
they said that also in 2020 i believe
with that one specifically so but other
ones you could choose so in the uk so i
wanted to say this we actually went back
and found this it's actually coming out
now people are starting to say hey wait
a minute this is there we went the
wayback machine and found it in 2020. do
you remember hearing that did it get
scrubbed in december of 2020 do you
remember hearing that from the uk saying
that breastfeeding and pregnant women
should not take the vaccine it's on
their website i don't remember hearing
that it would have been a major story
right my wife wouldn't have been forced
by her work to get the vaccine while
both pregnant and breastfeeding the big
difference though is now on social media
platforms and you you're allowed to say
maybe it's not good exactly mothers but
back then we couldn't say it no
this is the problem like look at a
certain point when do you ever take
accountability for banning information
that hey if it saves one life
hey if it saves one baby
if it saves one nursing mother where did
that go that only only applies when
you're talking about the second
amendment which by the way saves far
more lives than it takes if it saves one
life let's remove everyone's ability to
defend themselves how about if it saves
one life the guidance said and the gold
standard was hey if you're breastfeeding
and we don't know don't put it in your
body yeah now that information isn't a
bannable offense everywhere uh where you
consume information meaning 90 of the
information facebook facebook when i say
that i feel like i have to repeat it ad
nauseam but facebook instagram google
youtube these that's two companies
twitter tick tock yeah well and here's
the thing with the cdc's information you
said that now we can bring that overlay
up so the uk left that guidance up right
so it's updated they had an updated
article it has that guidance not to take
it if you're breastfeeding not because
of adverse effects but they don't know
just like you said
not the cdc the cdc strongly endorses
it's safe for breastfeeding moms and for
pregnant women cbc still has that on
their website now i don't know which
science to trust today they have it on
their website it conflicts with the uk
can we get that sportscaster with a
bizarre doll's eyes we need that yeah
yeah so let me know which science i
should trust
so i don't know what you're seeing right
now with aaron rodgers this is the kind
of thing where we would have had to
tread lightly just rebroadcasting what
joe rogan
you know created that he conducted a
great interview with her and roger did
the same with mark zuckerberg that was
actually far more uncomfortable to watch
but if we were to simply relay to you
that information
we have been we were back we were
suspended what in the last years have
been three times four times one of which
was for a cdc quote one of which was
either masks or vaccines and then the
other one recently why were we suspended
recently the last week yeah why was it
again carrie luck
oh that was carrie like the election
thing well we got suspended for oh don't
worry that'll change too by the way if a
republican wins the next election
retroactively uh you'll be allowed to
discuss uh all of the uh election issues
that don't exist so just keep this in
mind hold their feet to the fire this is
why we make all the references publicly
available so that you can always
contrast then and now
[Music]
i i i've talked about i'm i i'm not
vaccinated are you gerald no
never dave
with all the ones that work yes oh so
the johnson and johnson you're a big
yeah yeah yeah i got that jay and jay
baby the one that doesn't need to be
refrigerated i bought a lot of their
stock
[Laughter]
oh i just bought stock in body bags yeah
we're gonna need to have this show run
until i'm 100.
i still have a lot of stock in amc i got
in late on that one no i was gonna do it
and
no
hey is that are we allowed to say that
i'm not telling you what you can do just
sometimes people have asked at one point
we weren't allowed to discuss this that
was also maybe running a follow-up
youtube scott think about that for a
second what is recognized and what is
given the privilege of being a public
utility treated as a platform youtube
facebook twitter they said
you may not even be able to say that
you're not vaccinated because it may
encourage people to remain unvaccinated
so
it's a gray area it's what we call
borderline content and by the way you'll
never know who determines that but uh we
do enjoy the protections and uh you know
the tax haven of uh being uh being a
public utility it's actually really
infuriating yeah it really is
infuriating that you're not especially
this being america and the part that we
live in i don't know where they want to
censor in other parts of the you know
the world right but we should be allowed
to say our opinions we should be allowed
to say the things that we want to say
and you certainly should be allowed to
question anything that goes into your
body yeah there's no reason that this
should have happened and now they're
looking back going oh we may have
overreached you shut down
the world yeah you're gonna say you're
gonna say it might have been an
overreach you're ruined lives right
you're like all right we made we made
amazon prime was still able to uh
deliver that that's true yeah we saw the
wealthiest increase their their net
worth by billions of dollars and now
they're just crying it by the way right
reich and his ilk are out there i can't
believe they're making all this money
like the whole lot just park the trucks
in the middle of nowhere and go this was
easier just to collect the checks yes
exactly
the whole world was a reverse motel sex
commercials we'll leave the light off
yeah
that was always fun too when they were
like look in every hotel you'd stay at
they're like we can't clean the room for
the three days you're in it it's like so
you can't even you're not even gonna pay
the five dollars the labor force and now
they still don't do it no now they just
trimmed it back and they still don't do
it yeah they still don't have room
service that was one of the few things
as you know crappy road comics if we
were lucky enough to stay in a hotel
that had room service remember you're
like oh gosh this is wonderful no longer
a thing like we can't it's uh you know
over the top it requires us to work yeah
we can't bring you a 48 hamburger right
i'm not saying i was financially
responsible no nobody was but it was
nice
i also didn't want to walk downstairs
yeah i know me neither i mean what am i
you can use my legs at two in the
morning come on i wanted them to give me
some ice cream in bed
jack lalanne
right with his juicer where he was
always yelling at his wife in the
commercials even though there's like
that little sub text like they just
clearly stayed married because it was a
business like oh any commercial from the
50s 60s or 70s it's just a man screaming
yeah woman put the juice put the carrots
in there put that i gotta do [ __ ] i
gotta do jumping jacks my [ __ ] of a
wife won't put the carrots in but this
juicer this juicer would work if my wife
weren't an idiot yes
i just got a new dishwasher because my
old one's broken and his wife's
paralyzed she says broken fence
they broke my thumbs jackie
never gets on the pope of greenwich
village i don't care
this brings us now to you'd like to
think that the government is looking out
for you mm-hmm and by the of course you
don't but i mean people like that
sportscaster what's his name i don't
know mike tarico that's mike his name is
mike
it's mike and mike it's somebody popular
like the candy i think it's terrible
it's mike and mike yeah not mike and ike
ugh i prefer the latter i know is that
tarico well because at least it's two
different names yeah well also it's it
serves a use it's tasty no not tarico
and what is it what's his name there
tokuno
uh mike trico is an african-american
gentleman so it's not
admonish him admonish him
quick to the admonish button
i believe it's clark duncan yes
you ain't black
whoops is it mr clark duncan you serious
mike doringo's like
i told him you better leave the mask on
boss
i get a little scared
unvaxed sometime
that's terrible i don't know
sportscasters sorry aaron rodgers
cornbread yeah
only he's he's more of a percy i didn't
know the sponge was supposed to be wet i
didn't know the ball was supposed to be
this this is mcturico
oh not even close wow that's he's not
even a display so what is this guy do we
know who this guy's name is i don't
watch keep in mind i know i know how to
catch who is this guy this guy it's one
of the mike greenberg i think oh yeah
sorry well that inspires confidence yeah
aaron rodgers what am i paying
researchers for how long does it find it
take to find that guy's name
you just googled it real full names of
mike and mike
i did but i don't think this is my phone
i don't think this is mike all right air
support i'm going to put you guys to the
test i'm going to make a research
request and you'll have 30 seconds
otherwise i'll probably okay
[Laughter]
see i was wrong completely
stephen quits do you want me to go on
the third channel
i didn't do it i'll do it i'll switch
i'm getting text a bunch right now which
means my friends are mad at me ten
minutes to find out the name of max
kellerman i don't watch morning sports
shows no not you he's that's not your
job he's the agent you are blameless hbo
boxing announcer you're a spotless lamb
in this
son of a
he's uh he's the boxing announcer for
hbo hbo
that's howard cosell yeah come on where
is howie
he got faxed
all right so uh you got mayo card
nope nope nope nope i don't know if
we're gonna say that
we have to wait another couple of years
i said he bought my old car yes he did
yeah he bought your old buick yep
nothing like a useless saber no that's
what he loves okay so this is canada my
uh
partially home country for people who
think that i can't run for president i'm
never going to run for president but
it's not because i was born in canada i
was born in detroit i was raised in
canada to be clear and i'm very ashamed
of it it's the silliest country in the
world
uh i would love to see us not a nuke no
but like a biochemical weapon can we
just keep it
just take it yeah that's what i'm saying
yeah just take it it's ours anyway yeah
you know take it you just you know you
get a few you get a few uh a few
franchises a couple of tugboats they're
navy we're just going to run up the flag
what are they going to do so in canada
now they're prime minister justin
trudeau this is this is true just 100
million this is a guy by the way who
seized bank accounts right assets for
truckers who simply wanted to protest
the lockdowns uh who simply which by the
way uh we now know according to the cdc
there should be no different guidance
for vaccinated or unvaccinated the
truckers back then in canada were saying
hey you know what we can't be treated
like second-class citizens we need to be
allowed to work now isn't it isn't it
interesting that trudeau is is still
flying in the face of the new science
in a lot of ways if you actually look at
the pulse it's not on full lockdown but
there are different policies for
vaccinated unvaccinated i don't know
what their new policies as far as going
in or leaving canada if they still have
the quarantine i think it's still that
but it's certainly more strict than the
united states and more strict than the
cdc
would actually recommend so who's the
science and i are now i don't understand
the rule book but i do know that he has
another um
science pet project that's 100 million
dollars
as an action plan to support uh the 2s
lgbtqi
this is a real thing i want you to hear
it
straight from the overly proud of
himself prime minister of canada's mouth
[Applause]
okay wrong clip sorry uh we have the
right one here he is the uh 2s
lgbtqi plus 100 million dollars and by
the way you need to understand that in
for canada that's the equivalent to like
50 trillion here in the united states
right they do not have a lot of money
yes no here he is
our government has been committed to
protecting the rights of two-spirit
lesbian gay bisexual transgender
absolute intersex
additional sexuality and gender
diversity
that's why i'm so excited
today to announce a historic first the
launch of canada's first ever 2s lgbtqi
plus
look at the flag pelosi should be
wearing that [ __ ] like a scarf
basically the flag is just a cosby
sweater
i'd like to announce
how long did he stand in front of the
mirror to get that 2s lgbtqia plus i
know he would rattle it off
like he was the in the wu-tang clan this
isn't that nice shirt from charleston
and by the way in case you needed any
more proof that the left that the
progress progressive leftism is a
religion they've now included two spirit
because we've gotten so far away from
the science it's it's a spirit thing no
no we're no longer at biological sex
we're no longer even at social
constructs of gender it's a spiritual
issue to spirit i still don't fully know
what it means neither i understand it to
be a queer who's part native american
no that's not even a joke that's my
general understanding not really i don't
know
i haven't the foggiest he's included two
spirit but he's put it at the end most
of the time now he they've jumped the
line yeah he's given them priority
they're leading with two spirits
and here's actually a spirit's one cup
yes this is
this is him this is him uh uh noting of
the program from the cbc and keep in
mind this is this is also
government-funded cbc the canadian
broadcasting corporation i grew up with
and and trudeau won because he promised
them more money than the other candidate
you need to know this so it was
literally when you watched the debates
one of them said i promised an extra 100
million dollars to the cbc why i i
promise indeed 150 million dollars to
the cbc do you think the cbc gave it
gave the better coverage too so when
people [ __ ] about corporate media at
least you have different choices there's
nothing worse than government media you
don't need to go to venezuela so here's
trudeau a quote he said 75 of the
funding will go toward community
organizations focused on diversity and
inclusion inclusion because that's where
the real work of support comes from
i don't even know what that means i know
the acronym 2s lgbt stands for
two-spirit lesbian gay bisexual
transgender queer intersex and
additional sexual
i'm just glad you could explain it
because for a minute i thought it was
something silly yes for a moment i was
worried it does remind me that we need
to uh guys there uh the interns pick up
a toilet paper for the our new
two-spirit bathroom one ply
two spirit ply okay
now the cbc
the herald of the plan is historic
for the 2s lgbt community
okay
here's the thing
historically and by the way great work
from gingersnap because i sent this to
him and i said hey did you guys notice
anything in this article
and right away i was like yeah they used
the wrong acronym like five times in a
row i said yeah can we just find a
couple of other articles that likely do
the same thing and he's like i took me
10 minutes i found like 50 which ones do
you want yeah
it's too many so the cbc the canadian
broadcasting corporation used 2s lgbt
okay
but trudeau clearly announced the plan
was for
the 2s
lgbtqi plus community
cbc forgot the qi plus that's the most
important part
luckily they corrected their error in
the very next paragraph
and explained prime minister justin
trudeau unveiled the strategy dubbed
canada's first federal 2s lgbtq
i plus action plan
okay so they use the right one
but then five paragraphs later they
screwed up again and use the acronym
2slg
they forgot three
of the letters slash call signs qi plus
qi plus plus queries it's like whatever
the hell else you think of so overall
the article switches back and forth four
times
in the announcement
[Laughter]
but you've got to get it right exactly
it just shows that no one knows anymore
right and this is it's prove it's like
they said hey we need to we need to
announce this with a release can we do
it in a way that very pointedly uh
undergirds jordan peterson's argument
how quickly do you think the lg and b
will be removed from this because
they're like oh we need to create an
organization well i want to get to that
in a second because i have my concerns
do you well there's been a few instances
yes yeah there have been but uh the
issue here is bill c-16 was compelled
it's hate speech if you don't use the
right gender pronouns well the cbc
should be tried
they're not including the full acronym
how can you be forced to comply this is
the issue it's entirely made up just
like
the science isn't entirely made up but
is entirely it's a very arbitrary
selection process as to which science is
legitimate that's the theme of today's
show with covid they picked and they
chose and they said you better comply or
we're going to ban you we're going to
make it so that you can no longer seek
further employment with language in
canada can't happen here yet because of
the first amendment but not if the left
had their way you think if the left had
their way they wouldn't have the exact
same speech policies as canada which by
the way resulted in a trial
and and in charge of our comedian friend
for a joke that was considered offensive
that's what happens in canada you have
to comply well i have to comply with
what whatever we use in that article at
that time you know how he said you can
audit a ham sandwich right anyone out
there you've committed several crimes
today most likely that's the problem
with the government that just creates
laws on top of laws on top of laws but
it's very clear it's
it's not opaque with canada
they can decide to jail you or they can
decide to charge you they can decide to
turn you into a criminal
for not using the language that they
made up that day and they are not
required to use even consistently
themselves now do you think that the
government is going to prosecute the
canadian broadcasting corporation funded
by the government of course not but you
will
jordan peterson would that's why he was
a lightning rod for literally saying i'm
not going to do it i won't be forced to
use your language because you can't even
you can't even decide on what it is
four times one article the reference is
available live with clear.com and this
isn't unique no we checked out some
other articles here's an article from
the hill
august
they randomly rotated between lgbt and
lgbtq uh an article about monkey pox now
here's the thing leave off the queer yes
think about this for a second
why
this umbrella is too broad this umbrella
lgbtq
what can anyone think of something that
would affect lesbians less than monkey
pox
unless they're stealing your [ __ ] and
using it like a lawn dart
at this point we should just throw s in
there for straight and we'll all be
equal
but that would be too many s's because
there's a 2s
i forgot there's spirits you have to
have a space for two double s think
about this umbrella i mean if you did it
with black people you have black people
some of them don't even accept
dominicans amongst their ranks who to
the untrained eye that looks like a
black guy right we don't say all black
people are the same that a guy from
zimbabwe is the same as a a guy from
haiti right we don't we don't think that
ever now can you think of two
you mean to tell me that gay william who
by the way is out there in the green
room right now our gay latino to the
right of a tail of the hunt agent
is the same as some two-spirited native
american
they're all under the same acronym
they'd probably put the asexual in there
as well the people who don't practice
sex at all
i don't even know i know what 98 of all
monkey pox cases are you know
sex between two men not with lesions but
specifically gay sex so is the remaining
is the remaining two percent
two-spirited or the reminds me i shook
his hand today
yeah well we have sanitizer oh good
i deluded it a little bit because we ran
a little low during covet oh yeah it
might just be some tito's and aloe
is that why i want a drink
lg
let me go i can't even unless i go back
to my notes it is two s l g b t q i plus
what's the i for
intersex oh right i thought it was q a i
p at one point because we had that show
where we were
now they're just getting rid of letters
wholesale oh yeah no as a matter of fact
we have back in 2015.
back in 2015 i crashed a feminist film
festival i was escorted in my underwear
um and i used as a
kind of a joke but not really an acronym
that is actually milder than this and
people accuse me of straw manning this
is me in 2015
with a crystal queer ball i've never
seen so many super outbacks where they
will be having breakout panels on rape
culture nerd culture lgbtqa
and a silent number five it's not really
about women's rights it's about
transgenderism it's about lgbtqai and
asylum extra cue
who could have known that i was only off
by
three numbers i said five it's two and i
didn't even have the s plus the silence
it's longer than i had
i've never walked out of any movie and
thought like you know there just wasn't
enough heterosexual sex in
this like i've never seen a movie for
the sex unless it's you know me alone
right what
oh
i was like you know what i mean pb
herman thing yeah pretty much yeah like
in the theater yeah you know me and
myself think about that that was a sex
scandal back then i forgot what's the
guy's name peter herman yeah paul rubens
paul rubin yeah he got caught
in an adult film theater doing what
people do in adult film theaters now is
it creepy is it gross sure of course is
that a scandal we now have we now have
drag queen strippers yeah well now at
the gymboree he's like man i just was
ahead of my time i guess no and now it's
positively quaint yeah exactly oh thank
god he just did it in the theater yeah
purple stallion you'd give him a
nickelodeon kid's choice award i feel
like it actually makes sense
although for the optics we won't he
won't get slimed well he's he's a
protected class
all right which by the way thank you
that's a great segue this brings us uh
to the diversity higher of the week
all right gerald because you know i know
nothing about sports what's the name of
this tennis player novak djokovic
djokovic i think you got that wrong i
didn't so i guess he's one of the
world's greatest tennis players and just
like we talked about with aaron rodgers
uh he's been refused entry to the united
states due to his unvaccinated status
apparently they didn't read the new cdc
it starts with a d the d silent
hillbilly
is it no mixing
ain't no mixing this is not the greg
louganis thing really he's on his own
side of the court you would think so
who's he
who's he hurting wait that's the
opposite of greg louganis
on the diving board and bled throughout
the pool well yeah but you weren't gonna
get aids from that it looked like when
the foot fell from the row boat and jaws
you know what's crazy he's still alive i
know i thought he was dead i know we
wrote a whole sketch i don't know the
whole sketch we wrote and then turned
out we found it he's alive yeah we
couldn't use the sketch on the fact that
we thought he was dead
but
honestly i'm kind of disappointed greg
louganis is still alive not that he
doesn't deserve to be alive right right
he's a good sketcher he's good no no
it's good that he'll have to wait yeah
so if you're noticing a train now
you have aaron rodgers okay so you have
this tennis player not allowed entering
the united states and i know that if
you've been watching the show from the
beginning you're saying well that
doesn't make sense because we just
talked about the vaccinated should be
treated the same as the unvaccinated and
i'm even allowed to say it on youtube
look we haven't even been suspended
because the cdc says it's okay
well um the uh the diversity higher here
is uh uh does she pronounce it
how did she say it kareem john pierre
she was asked why illegals are welcome
to enter the country if they're
unvaccinated uh but the world's greatest
tennis player is not and it seems like a
valid question and you would think that
she would have an answer that um you
know is in the realm of making sense
absolutely not
how come migrants are allowed to come
into this country unvaccinated but
world-class tennis players are not are
you you're talking about which
world-class tennis player novak djokovic
so as far
you know
just to just
since you asked about me about him yes
me about him so visa records are
confidential
under u.s law
therefore the u.s government cannot
discuss the details of individual visa
cases
due to privacy reasons the us government
also does not comment on medical
information of individual travelers as
it relates to
the tennis the tennis place
player
to those asking she's not [ __ ]
now you sure
she did
give it her level best on the second
go-around
to answer the question and if you're
thinking okay so this one's going to be
better because you know uh strike two
absolutely not
so they're two different things they're
two different things but so are how's it
two different things
somebody unvaccinated comes over on a
plane you say that's not okay somebody
walks into texas or arizona unvaccinated
they're allowed to stay
why but that's not how it works like we
actually know we know that that's not
what you guys want to happen but that is
what has happened but that's not it's
not like somebody walks over and
that's not that's not how
[Music]
some of them
turn themselves over some of them are
caught tens of thousands a week are not
that is what is happening
hmm
yeah i mean i
i don't know
how she's not prepared for this
considering that this was the policy
that was released from the white house
and these are these uh documents are
confidential except of course he shared
them with you yes and it told the entire
world that he was not going to be able
to play tennis because you wouldn't let
him in because he's unvaccinated also
the fact that we publicly released the
policy that unvaccinated immigrants
would be treated the same so i don't
understand the question and i won't
respond to it not because i'm a black
lesbian but because i'm horrible at my
job and that's been the diversity higher
of the week
has nothing to do with black lesbianism
hold on can you get it she was handed
like okay here's your answer we just
don't talk about that but he's told the
whole world yeah but we don't um we
don't talk about that she makes you miss
jenn sackey yeah i know ginsaki's got to
just be like yeah there you like that
now
and you wonder if i would have made it
trust our institutions the spokesperson
for the white house for the president
united states says we're not going to
discuss something that is public
knowledge from the other individual who
has waived any confidentiality problem
well a true lady doesn't strip a
fundamental rights intel no
that's a problem she's not a lady answer
everything by just going uh i'm a
lesbian next question
and if you have a problem with that it's
because she's not lesbians
i she is a lesbian she has a wife yeah i
know she says that you think it's a
beard the other way yeah well maybe she
swings her i think it's a i think it's a
big old muff to throw us off the center
that's true whenever she's that bad at
her job she's got to have something
going for you yeah it's a it's a decoy
beaver
now
[Laughter]
that'll be the biggest outrage of the
show right now a decoy fever
we're gonna have a shirt made of that
i don't care go build a damn shut
yourself in now
it's a little marsupial humor it's
literally a beaver
[Laughter]
it's just you look over there's just
like a woodchuck
in
wearing doc martens how much karen
jean-pierre would have karen john pierre
chuck if a karen johnson
it's a tongue twister welcome which is
what she does yeah just abundant wooden
house on a
river why does your home look like
lemony snickets on a creek bed
i'm a lesbian i'm sorry no further
questions no it's just so well go ahead
we eat mostly berries by the way smash
the like button if you're
okay with what you've been watching
smash it finish it or even if you're not
take it
how do you like it how do how well i'm
not going to say how did she get the job
i'm going to move right on from there
because she's a fantastic thing
no i think it's just because uh she
knows how to answer questions yes yeah
she speaks really well for other people
spin city do you think it's almost like
you know how when you have comics who
they don't want someone good yeah open
for them correct
do you think that's why joe biden was
like have her speak for me oh yes i need
somebody that's going to make me look
you saw kaylee mackel in it and he was
like i can't follow that no no way and
it really is true by the way dave talked
about this like when when we do these
shows too in houston phoenix like
we'll switch either sometimes dave will
go up or i'll go up one kind of switch
we do the same amount of time it makes
you better knowing if ever i if ever i
follow dave i'm like well i better bring
the a-game because otherwise i'm going
to absolutely bomb but not if i had like
a the comedic equivalent of carrying
john pierre well yeah you don't want
crap in front of you and you shouldn't i
hate when people do that it's like i
just bring somebody off on the road and
give them money right why would you
encourage that like dice yeah oh hey you
suck you want to open for me yeah yeah
he's 200
give me 20 minutes oh
all right
uh do we have time to get to this all
right i think it ties us together pretty
nicely uh uh science is just let's just
put the final nail in the coffin it's
dead so nature magazine published a new
guideline uh on august 18th
uh that basically destroys the ability
for the scientific community to conduct
any type of research well good they're
not using it
right just they're just making
proclamations so and they even actually
address this because you would think
that hey the scientific process and this
is why i love seeing this i love seeing
this house of cards come tumbling down
remember when you had the dawkins of the
world or the sam heiresses of the world
where they actually the scientific
process right it's full proof that it's
not subject to human error right and it
becomes more and more subject to human
error the more humans
become involved with this process namely
bureaucracy look at what happened and
this is not new science has been used to
justify all kinds of atrocities people
always say religion's the cause of all
wars religion had nothing to do with
hitler by the way just to be clear
hitler sometimes tried to appease
christian people even though he wasn't
himself it was largely based on science
that's how he othered the jews he talked
about hereditary diseases he talked
talked about communicable diseases
started with science they're unclean
they're a danger so this idea that
science cannot be used uh when falsely
applied as a form of control of your
population well it flies in the face of
not only science but history but they
actually say this out loud
at uh nature magazine they say although
academic freedom is fundamental it is
not unbounded this is a scientific
argument of well you can't yell fire in
a crowded theater right first amendment
that's what they're trying to do
what do they say they say okay people
can be harmed indirectly meaning science
for example research may inadvertently
stigmatize individuals or human groups
it and this is where it gets uh
hilarious
sorry i meant scientific terrifying it
may be discriminatory racist sexist
ableist or homophobic it may provide
justification for undermining the human
rights of specific groups simply because
of their social characteristics then
they go on to say potential harms to the
populations studied may outweigh the
benefit of publication
so
this can mean no published research by
the way for gender sexuality obesity uh
racially linked diseases for example
sickle cell is something that obviously
is uh and by the way i don't think black
people are saying don't study sickle
cell that's racist i would think they'd
like to fix the sickle cell i'm french
canadian there are a bunch of actually
hereditary diseases that are exclusive
to the uh the acadian and french
canadian bloodlines also that's the
reason we had so many strong women
there's a guy named louis seer had the
same uh hereditary condition that eddie
hall has regarding myostatin it's
basically a chemical that tells you
tells the the sausage casing of your
muscles uh it tells it to stop growing
too much muscle and if you don't have
that your muscles can just grow grow
grow grow grow louis seer had it and a
guy like eddie hall had it and these all
come from the acadian french canadian
blood it's not that we're saying they're
lesser than we are saying that people of
different ethnicities have different
sometimes nutritional requirements
vitamin d is different in white people
and black people but that might be
discriminatory uh you can't study any uh
disabilities uh sexually transmitted
diseases like aids hiv uh monkey pox gun
violence you can read the article so if
we're not supposed to study any of these
things
[Music]
it's [ __ ] is it just science now is
opinion yeah yeah yeah left is just
saying yeah is that what it is yeah yeah
i just want to make sure yeah they don't
want to study anything anymore and
go ahead what we're going to say i was
going to say by the way they might want
to maybe look into the monkey box saying
because there's kids getting it
and lesbians and dogs getting it yeah
and lesbians because they've just been
yeah lorena vomiting and javeling it
yeah they're like the
the one lone lesbian in the world just
play the lottery you'll probably hit
that first yes we have an epidemic of
lesbians shot putting penises into other
lesbians riddled with monkey pops you
know that thing they hate
look if you're gonna cut it off
recycle
and here's the thing this is not a joke
we have all of the references available
today is probably one of the most
important days not one research diseases
no no
it's fat pride only turn put on steroids
yeah i'm just glad being italian and
irish we're not prone to anything right
yes exactly
like alcoholism and obesity
anger and being loud no just being
obnoxious have you ever heard any loud
italian person freckles never once with
the irish oh i don't think i've ever
seen that so this is probably one of the
most important days for you to check the
references because i know that what i'm
saying sounds unbelievable and it's
always funny because you will hear
critics of the show so oh they don't
even listen no we always list the
references and i don't always list them
on twitter if you want to know what
we're actually saying about a subject
come and watch the show don't just take
a tweet it's the worst platform twitter
instagram to actually communicate your
thoughts of course sometimes things have
to be edited down that don't include the
entire context every show every day we
provide all the resources to you and i
know that some of this seems like we're
making it up
this is real we actually have to worry
about the feelings of microbes as well
i'm going to read a quote so you know
i'm not lying these guidelines apply to
studies involving humans vertebrate
animals and uh and cell lines that's
what they actually write so
sorry queer spirulina i have i'm sorry
that we are
outside
i didn't see that yet
actually i was debating with going with
that or chlorella because it might be
more accurate since it's an actual
single cell walled organism or spirulina
is what they would consider open i also
i was trying with the idea of a blue
klamath lake algae it's a genre of humor
i think the leatherman is the way to go
yes the leatherman
in in the village people every everybody
was a job and it was just so prone back
then that leather man was too
like oh does he work with leather like
is he a tanner no no no no he just hangs
out in san francisco in the meat
district right
and by the end it was really more vinyl
man they had
wasn't wearing a full grain yeah you
really couldn't afford it
yeah i'm vinyl man you can't ruin your
leather every weekend
you have to treat it rub open ups on it
the point is it's too expensive and so
you know what you let them do what they
do we're actually going to talk more
about this and also
some speculation regarding the fbi
recently and to build a guy who was just
sort of escorted and i will tell you uh
i would not feel comfortable discussing
it on youtube because not all the
information is in we have to make some
inferences so that is your warning and
we're gonna take your chat youtube thank
you very much we will see you tomorrow
uh but right now
piss off
you